une quantité de 9 litres de glaces et
pour faire 9 litres de glaces jeu mais
90 jaune d'oeuf 1 fabriqué dans une
ferme laitière cette gourmandise est
réalisée sans arômes artificiels sans
colorant la glace pistache à l'hiver
clair elle n'est pas vert foncé et la
glace à la mentale et blanche du sucre
des gousses de vanille et de la gomme de
caroube viennent s'ajouter au lait
entier et à la crème dans la machine le
mélange est pasteurisé puis glacée est
là à 8 degrés pour qu'elle soit
bonne prêtes à manger il faut qu'elle
soit -10 degrés à ses glaces de la ferme
sont ensuite mis en pots vendus sur
place mais aussi dans les restaurants
certains supermarchés et dans plusieurs
écoles locales est à l'origine de ces
douceurs la nourriture de ces vaches
laitières
un mélange de maïs d'herbe de blé de
pommes de terre il y a quelques années
cet éleveur a pris le risque de
diversifier son activité
on a eu la crise 2009 les tiers qui
arrivait en menant même moment quoi donc
ça a été un peu compliqué fait un sermon
seniors on met pas les oeufs dans le
même panier mais on va essayer de
trouver une autre filière un peu de
glace était pas mal quand après on est
parti là tu sais quoi au début oui on
nous a pris pour des rigolos on va dire
de la glace à droué non mais vous vous
êtes tombé sur la tête quoi et puis bah
si si ça va marcher n'y a pas de raison
puis oh là aujourd'hui et c'est plutôt
ils sont tous adopté le produit quoi la
crème glacée représente 5% du chiffre
d'affaires de l'exploitation laitière
une audace aujourd'hui devenu une
activité rentable